the star wars civil war continues people
rumor has it Kathleen Kennedy might be
stepping down we covered the last story
that was breaking about this like last
week about you know they might be
resetting the Star Wars trilogy hiding
the sequels in the Vale of the force
which was funny just a really stupid
rumor most likely is right but now
Kathleen Kennedy stepping down you tell
me that I'm likely to believe it
considering everything just the fact
that her name has seeped into the
greater Star Wars Canon in a villainous
kind of way yes Star Wars fans for
better for worse and I automatically
don't think she'd want to keep doing it
that's just my opinion I was her I would
be totally soured on the 68 to do I mean
you know say what you will about the
films for the crime of trying to bring
you all a new Star War I think I would
feel pretty weird coming back after all
of this yeah and please keep in mind
this is not an opinion piece on the
movies themselves that I'm talking about
right now I'm just talking about what it
must be like to be in Kathleen Kennedy's
position that's strictly where I'm
coming from on this but let's go through
this article Star Wars reset includes
Kathleen Kennedy stepping down details
once again come from the future ruler of
Earth Lord doom [ __ ] everyone's favorite
source from the overlord DVD YouTube
channel you know I want to just really
see what you want to see what he looks
like
who is the future ruler of her overlord
fun he looks like a like a like a power
ranger but also MF DOOM it's like
anonymous this is like a V for Vendetta
status but with you know with Star Wars
I've already made a full conclusion what
the channel is about a recall it was
doom Kaka revealed all those Star Wars
the rise of Skywalker spoilers and doom
[ __ ] even revealed trouble at Disney
with brie Larson prior to the directing
and writing team
being like Oh from the Captain Marvel
sequel did you know that brie Larson got
a flat tire on her way to an audition
for terminator and didn't get it you
know why because brie Larson is the
worst yeah no she's here on YouTube to
steal all the subscribers from Marvel's
gonna pay I heard a review the
personally hate brie Larson I've met her
and I know Star Wars Civil War taking
place at Lucasfilm doom [ __ ] has gone on
record stating sources have filled him
in that a source no man if you guys
haven't seen my leaking new segment
about Disney buys the rights of the
Bible I hope you appreciate it might
seem very hypocritical to be covering
this in a genuine way but you know
there's irony in everything so in that
sense we're keeping with the zeitgeist
yeah you know where I guess we're just
hypocrites I will just say that I guess
everyone's a hypocrite a little bit doom
[ __ ] has gone on record saying sources
have filled him in that a secret plan in
the works to save Star Wars that
involves some sort of Star Wars civil
war taking place at Lucasfilm between
Kennedy and those loyal to Lucas Favreau
and Dave Filoni just imagine what
Kathleen Kennedy in a bunch a woman
imagine Kathleen Kennedy alone and then
Lucas Favreau felonious just an army of
dudes behind the cardboard cutouts of
female bodies to get boiled down through
that and I think it's kind of sad
because I wonder I I don't want to be
that guy but I'm gonna like what would
happen if the producer was just another
dude like I looked up her credits before
shooting this video and she is produced
like so many beloved films an executive
proved entire Back to the Future
franchise as good as your last movie
apparently only as good as your Star
Wars movie and demon problems yeah doom
[ __ ] previous supporters say that the
Star Wars reset will involve the erasure
of the force awakens yeah yeah their
concept introduced in Star Wars rebels
animated series the Vale of the force
and here's what he says Kathleen
Kennedy's rate of terrorism
southern end I've been sitting on this
information for weeks now seeking
further confirmation but at this point
I've heard enough from various
viewpoints to credit this rumor may have
some validity to it it's explained that
Kennedy is dead set against the plan as
it will undo everything she has done
with Disney Star Wars it attacks her
legacy in a fundamental way it's a stain
rebuke to her authority and vision and
repudiation pewdie a repudiation who's
in this video a brand of identity
politics and a signal to a grateful
world that the force isn't female at all
but belongs to everyone
dog yes so Finn was trying to tell Ray's
like that's why can't you see the plan
to save Star Wars couldn't happen with
Kennedy in charge of Lucasfilm which
means when her contractor inspires in
2021 she is oh god out dead nearly a
month ago my source notified me that a
big meeting had taken place regarding
the future of Lucasfilm Bob Iger and Bob
chap ik both participated in the meeting
which is significant but even more
significant was who did not participate
in the meeting Kathleen Kennedy the head
of Lucasfilm I am informed that Kennedy
never never never misses meetings
meetings meetings like these and so her
absence was notable one would think a
meeting about the future of Lucasfilm
would include the head of Lucasfilm but
according to my source Kennedy did not
participate in this meeting I don't know
if I made it clear enough but Kennedy is
so important do we know why it's clay
maybe it was a zoo meeting and they she
couldn't get her internet properly
working it's a claim that a few days
prior to the big meeting Kennedy had a
meeting of her own that lasted an hour
and after she left
Kennedy wood drew from contact with
underlings and okay
right hand contacted the staff which is
predominantly female important detail if
not exclusively in report evade the
following message on behalf of Kathleen
Kennedy miss Cathy has decided she will
not be pursuing an extension of her
contract so many of you wish to stay
with her you best be making your minds
up you have time there is no need for
any rash decisions and miss Cathy has
plans to open a female centric
production company and if you choose not
to have this contract ongoing with her
you're a sexist plain and simple
accordion if you're a man you should try
and get into that female centric company
I'm so unsexy courting the tune [ __ ] at
the meeting Kennedy attended saw Kennedy
provided with data regarding House Star
Wars has been falling under her
leadership yeah now we know that movies
merchandise and parks have been
downtrending something I have been
covering for years at this point I have
been informed that Kennedy's contract
will not be renewed all right she'll be
going to create her own production
company her leadership will be missed
did doom Cox say that's contradictory
but Disney looks forward to what
Kathleen will do with her new company if
this is true it appears that Kathleen
Kennedy reign of terror Wow I have to
believe that this was delivered with a
tongue in its cheek otherwise oh my god
whatever funny about this is even if you
even if you really believe it's a state
of like pandering or forced agendas or
diversity things like that if you if you
genuinely believe that okay I fail to
see how the intent of wanting to
represent that though is a terrible
malicious yeah that's the part of the
argument I don't get well and why people
only place it on Kathleen Kennedy when
Disney across the board does this as do
many companies you know like the very
sensibility they're complete people
complain about with the Star Wars sequel
is apart from the
and in lore stuff but you know the
sensibility is across the board Disney
here's the Kathleen Kennedy determine
finally be near its and Anna reign of
terror is exactly when it's rumored to
have been after the financial success of
the force awakens Kennedy was foolishly
given free rein to do whatever she
wanted with the last Jedi the result was
a sham a crass and tasteless propaganda
film a shameless checklist of woke
talking points overflowing with virtual
signalling and contempt for what Kennedy
perceives as the patriarchy utterly
devoid of narrative coherence creative
integrity or anything resembling star
Wow Oh
kudos let me get you a hankie my friend
that's well that's well it's completely
over the top but it is a like if this
was about some like real world war
monger oh yeah Kennedy had her way with
Star Wars in an almost biblical sense
and then said about changing culture and
mission of Lucasfilm stacking the staff
with feminist ideologues and we dare any
employees that fail to live up to our
political litmus tests case in point
Dave Filoni I don't want to argue with
Star Wars fans about if last Jedi was a
real Star Wars movie or not I don't want
to do that anymore you know what they're
all made up all fantasies I feel like
this is a little overdramatic it's very
awesome
I think that's the funny thing - to me
about it
like I said if you do think these
agendas seem to be more about agenda
based and not enough about narrative
Star Wars proper storytelling then all
right fine I just don't think it is this
hellstorm is wonderfully worded as well
yeah and it reads poured to me because
especially being like ah you know the
whole goal of stacking the deck with
feminist idea
logs and whatnot and I'm like some of
this stuff you're talking about yes is
clunky in its integration to the movie
but it's not unfair to be like let's
represent more people in the Star Wars
because there's literally a vast
universe with like tons of aliens and up
until recently one black person in ways
I do think that that there's a bit of an
ideological breakdown that some Star
Wars fans are gonna want that progress
and some aren't
again wonder if these things had
happened in a more fluid way would
anyone have noticed I mean did I miss
some rapport I'm obviously doing the
most general paraphrasing in the world
here did I miss some rapport where a man
named Brian Johnson had a specific
vision for the last Jedi and then
Kathleen Kennedy stepped in and said I
have some woke things I want in this
movie or else no no because I've been
under the impression the thing that
happened with last Jedi where everything
went wrong for Star Wars fans that's the
impression I got yeah yeah and then post
that you got solo and you got Lord and
Miller doing a little too much of their
thing on the heels of that and then you
get them removed yes that's why I find
the whole vitriol this whole thing about
woek agenda not a productive argument
because I thought the issue was Rian
Johnson did whatever he wanted not he
wanted to do something and Kathleen
Kennedy was like no you got to put all
this other [ __ ] in here yeah really
I don't know that's just not what I feel
like Rian Johnson wanted to subvert it's
the meme of that movie as subverting
expectations and I feel like he wanted
to subvert a lot of action movie and and
sci-fi adventure movie tropes with the
choices that he made it yeah she was
probably on board with some of those
choices but it does track a little funny
to me to call so much attention to that
be like this woman executive producer
who's the head who wants to start this
female centric company who loaded her
team with feminists ruined all this
stuff when yeah like we're the last Jedi
it seems like Ryan Joss and Jen JJ
Abrams comes back and he gets to
course-correct and kowtow to fans and it
seems like a lot of dudes are calling
shots even still on Star Wars it's just
maybe those dudes aren't exactly the
right team either I mean it
in between Kathleen Kennedy a step below
would be the directors who have all been
men yeah and then above Kathleen Kennedy
would be Bob iger's so maegyr if you
look at those ads that play on instagram
for his master class the first thing
he's like we're all about inclusion here
at Disney we want as many different
kinds of people to see themselves
represented in our films possible I mean
maybe he's just saying that I think
that's why being woke has got in such
one of the reasons that I think woke has
gotten such a bad rap corporations who
don't don't get it don't truly I mean
first off woke just used to apply to
black people yeah that's what it first
applied to and then somehow the this is
a whole this is like a very very long
off tangent conversation where you get
into but somehow it's become about a
whole bunch of things that have been
sort of like culturally appropriated and
become canceled culture and I'm like
that so it though being woke actually
first meant about seeing through
[ __ ] to the truth it was it was
mainly just for like it really erupted
during the black lives matter movement
many years ago and then it was mainly
just dealing with racial and justices
now no one could really even define my
point where that is there are people who
claim to be a part of what culture but
can't define it and then there are
people who hate whoa culture and they
can't even define it well cos it's
pressurized there's like this onus on us
all I mean yeah you theoretically in an
ideal world we would all want to be what
being woke is trying to get at which is
just you know seeing as much of the
world for what it is as possible yeah
and you know treating people with that
kind of respect that comes with that I
feel like it comes down to the fact that
yeah there are some people who are still
learning I mean it's it's something that
affects us all and yeah you watch these
studio since stuff basically try to
commodify it because I think you get two
halves basically you get the people who
actually are paying attention and
learning who are authentically kind of
making them mistakes but also learning
through them and then you have the
people who are posturing and trying to
appear as woke as possible just to
fortify the brand and I think that there
is a lot of that because you get these
people in boardrooms and we've had
leaked emails before to suggest that at
least some of the things these producers
talked about behind this
are a bit as silly as you might imagine
and yeah like I can totally hear
producers chatting back and forth in my
head going ah can we the kids want to be
woke these days we get in here once
being diverse or representation became
trendy then suddenly you could feel
where the disingenuous qualities come
from and now at least on the online
world that's what what culture is now
associated with is all the negative
stuff and so it's kind of it's sad when
you think about it it's yeah what woke
used to represent and now what woke
culture has the spotlight on it is just
negative things it's no longer a
positive Association when the whole
thing was originally up anyway
this is something I could do a whole
podcast about did you not have been down
the wormhole up yeah I saw a video where
someone was like what does well culture
mean and then I found myself going like
wait what does whoa Coetzer mean and
then I decided to go through like oh
this actually started like many many
many many years ago and suddenly like
well here's where to start up tit into
early 2000s and then a few years ago
black lives matter and then and then
watching the trajectory did a whole
bunch of research on it yeah there's
like two hours of trying to understand
what are the things that people have
issues with the world culture and what
is well culture actually about and then
now what is spotlight is all on it's a
whole you can't sum it up in like five
minutes you can't it's uncountable
because it calls you to look at yourself
and to confront things that you might
not be comfortable with and I think that
that's the ultimate thing is if you calm
a lot of people down who are upset about
this I don't think anybody would have
that hard of a time agreeing that yeah
like we should have every kind of person
in a Star Wars movie and you know maybe
they should do a couple different things
with them but the problem is it becomes
especially with the label just this big
faceless force and are these people who
overreact to stuff and who just want a
social justice up my movie there's more
nuance to it than that then people don't
get credit for it's not black and white
topic yeah I mean that in a race way I
mean that in like a cat in a category
with it's an all-or-nothing discussion
here yeah and I think that's the that's
a big issue with what's happening is
we've lost what the group we were not
aware of the grey area of this anymore
and people attribute this as the thing
that is ruining at least a certain group
in tribute is this is the thing that
ruined the Star Wars is the woke culture
effect on it when really it's just you
know some inconsistent decisions
maybe a little lack of foresight you
know certain things like that and hey
foresight force ghosts but maybe you
know and maybe at the end of the day
Kathleen Kennedy in Star Wars is just
not the best creative pairing and that's
fine too yeah I just don't think that
she's this evil overlord who kicked in
the door and was like I wanna ruin the
Star Wars for you or I want to make it
only my thing because those movies are
clearly trying to reach the widest
audience possible still I feel like even
if her intent with it wasn't realized to
the best extent it could have been
I still like really it kind of upsets me
the way people just dog pile the vitriol
on top of it oh yeah I mean that's the
that's a shitty thing about it that's
why I brought Brian Johnson with this
because I've seen barely any mention I
don't I haven't heard his name once in
this and I'm bringing up the woke thing
because like everything I said was not
necessarily a defense for what whoa
culture has sort of turned into that's
not why I brought it up I brought it up
because I don't think what culture is
the problem yeah because I remembered
that it was Ryan Johnson had too much
free rein yeah and somehow the
discussion has turned into whoa culture
has ruined struggle and ideals ideas
that harmonize with woken asar going to
inevitably appear in a movie that is a
Nazi allegory I mean if we're taking
down an evil discriminatory dictator
Empire I guess my question is is if
Kathleen Kennedy was a guy Kevin Kennedy
or something right he was a guy and he
said me Kennedy he said Ryan Johnson do
your own thing with the anymore and
Johnson made exactly the last Jedi would
it still have to morphed into this you
know what I mean yeah that's good that's
basically why I brought all that up and
we're not trying to hear some it's not
really like it's not my fault that I got
like a little bit of a political talking
here one of the things people hate about
this is either yeah that the last Jedi
just really spat in the face of the
mythology or they're just woken up my
Star Wars and they're real throwing it
in my face and and the disingenuous Ness
of that is worth taking issue with not
the ideals themselves and and I feel
like a lot of people get lost in the
woods they're you know fighting against
something that we ought not to be and
I'll
I've said it several times I'm gonna
repeat it again if I miss something
about Ryan Johnson and being forced to
put in quote unquote
woek agendas let me know I haven't heard
anything about it well Ryan Johnson's
trilogy is just all gonna be about like
a black queer trans gray Jedi you know
just like totally dismantling all which
I mean I would I would go watch moving
on with this article
the acrimony is genuine Lucasfilm is a
house at times bitterly divided and
there is indeed a new hope for Star Wars
as a number of positive changes a rumor
to be coming again as previously
explained the plan is to use the veil of
the force to cancel out Kennedy's sequel
trilogy Andy canonizing zoom [ __ ] also
points out that Kathleen Kennedy leaving
Disney and Lucasfilm looks to be true
because of the recent announcement
regarding Star Wars Celebration getting
pushed back by two years which is the
year after Kennedy's contract expires
that's fair it could have a wide variety
of things though you know the you know
the fact that they don't really know
what they're doing with their movies yet
and usually I mean start where
celebration is going on for a long time
but there's anyway why pretty cancel the
event for 2021 after all no one has an
idea what the situation with the
contagion will be like from a year from
now why not just wait and see why
postpone it's the event to 2022 well my
friends asked herself what will of ended
by 2022 the answer is simple Kathleen
Kennedy talked about pushing agenda
starting in 2010 82 Disney wants to
start fresh with the franchise and bring
the old fans back he says the Star Wars
Celebration 2022 was to the announcement
of a new head of Lucasfilm if not prior
and that Kennedy will be moving on it
would indeed be a significant reset for
Lucasfilm and would generate genuine
heat or revamp Star Wars movie back to
the basics Lucas originally intended and
away from the dive device of identity
politics that has crippled the franchise
and divided the fan base it said that
one source is stating Jon Favreau will
be named as the new head of Lucasfilm
however another source of doom Cox says
it a completely neutral party will be
brought in as a no that's interesting
looking forward to calm down all the
internal problems and start fresh ha an
additional rumor is also saying that the
Star Wars products including galaxy's
edge will get remodeled to include
actual Star Wars
for the family what does that actual you
mean is it because the the Gauchos edge
is mainly based on the latest trilogy
and not really about celebrating the
original trilogy that's honestly all
this being said if you made it to this
point of the video
I think Kathleen Kennedy should step
though I think that there's elements of
Star Wars and this recent one where
perhaps certain things were agendas were
being pushed maybe I don't
to me it's not as obvious as other
things but to some it's apparently it's
like extremely obvious okay I'm not
gonna say no yeah because they obviously
wanted to include representation same
time like a lesson it's very mild like a
couple of lesbians kissing at the end of
rises and you have to really like oh
wait a minute it was that a couple gays
right there yeah yeah and the irony is
that that isn't even doing that yeah and
that's what I mean we're there a lot of
female centric characters yeah there are
a lot of dudes to slide other than fact
there was more of a female presence in
the recent edition of Star Wars I didn't
pick up on anything about it being woman
deserved to be more recognized do you
know what I mean yeah it's like yes you
got ray you got jyn erso you got hold
though you know you gotta you got the
whole like you know Poe you a stand down
thing and the reasoning from hold o not
being terrific for that and you know for
him not to go off you know and you know
be rogue and go fight you know rashly or
whatever in the last Jedi was that a
comment on the sexes was just like in a
more normal you know space
action-adventure the dude would just be
like I know what to do and I'm gonna
follow my gut and I'm gonna go do it and
instead of that he's checked and you
know kind of told like hey your rash
behavior might actually be a detriment
to us which is like kind of subversion
of a trope
I thought that was Ryan Johnson trying
to do something with a character both
giving that character about like I
thought again and that's the thing I
thought was at least interesting in the
nugget the whole Finn and Poe [ __ ] was
kind of boring
right I'm not I'm not gonna defend it
like it was good if you were telling
guys I feel like there was really some
hardcore agenda pushing they would not
have bitched out on making those two
dudes in love like they I for as much as
there was fan me Murray and people being
like come on make Finnegan like in poen
and and John boyega and and Oscar Isaac
you were even for that and look it's not
it's not our fault that we're focusing
on this this whole article it comes in
this whole discussion has yeah it's if
it's evolved into this and it's devolve
Jesus I'm not like the one who's like
I'm turning this video into it this is
kind of like sad it is because we feel
like we're just mad at the wrong thing I
honestly could hear you out if you if
you were like this is not proper Star
Wars this is not proper star like that I
could totally hear you on I thought
Captain Marvel was like you say that
[ __ ] about Captain Marvel yeah I'm like
gosh it's like very aware yeah there's
stuff in there like you're you're you're
really putting that there are certain
scenes where you're putting that the
Fernan center there's yeah definitely
scenes that come out like a feminist
theory yeah
like that one I could see it at this
though I just didn't see it other than
the fact that you had more females well
and pretty much it but the big thing I
wonder especially especially especially
about these Star Wars sequels is what
would we have all been sitting here
talking about had we lived in a slightly
different culture where there isn't so
much made out of that because also when
those movies are coming out in the
lead-up to right at the time they're
dropping there's all this talk about
like Oh Rose Tico first ever Asian
female this and and like there's so much
of a deal made out of it in both the
positive and the negative light I wonder
if we just hadn't been talking that much
about it
would this be as big of an issue on this
movie because it's just in the cultural
consciousness to a degree that I feel
like people can also get overly
sensitive on the opposite side and
attack it where it doesn't deserve to be
attacked and it only really ever
deserves it if it's disingenuous you
know exactly you know sometimes it's
very apparent what they're doing most
likely I'm likely to believe that they
were like we need to cast an Asian
person for this we need to cast a woman
I could see that right which is fair
it's it's a it's fair in a time where
there
disproportionate cast with the producer
mentality and whatever or maybe the
writer director wanting to like include
that more for whatever intention they
have right I guess the thing though is
the story itself naked about that other
than casting yeah what's the story the
narrative or the theme what was it about
it most likely I'm likely to believe it
they were like we should make Rose Tico
an Asian girl I could see that there was
nothing in that movie that was about
Rose being an Asian girl other than the
fact that Rose was an Asian girl she's a
prominent character and that's the
different thing about that you know all
that being said I think Kathleen Kennedy
should step down because the movies just
have not connected I would hate to look
at their line graph and be like oh man
that's a really I would hate to see that
there are people who are probably better
suited right now in the cultural
zeitgeist or which is well more versed
in Star Wars like people like Dave
Filoni people like John Favreau yes
there are two white dudes alright but
I'm not even making it about that the
point they would be better to do it the
point the ultimate point is yeah finding
who best to honor the spirit and the
core idols of Star Wars that's what's
important to this conversation whoever
that may be sir mean it's it's not all
or nothing like I don't know and I don't
agree with so much of what culture
agenda being pushed in here but I can
also tell you Kathy Kennedy she
continued here and it's not toxic and
it's not it's beyond that - it's like
it's clearly like that yes the toxicity
with the fans of the the uh appreciation
that factors into my reasoning for why
she should step down
absolutely I don't think that her the
way she has you need someone like a
Kevin Feige who can oversee a franchise
like this in a way that is creative and
also is able to keep the fans happy and
just what they've been dishing out
they're been on too many strikes coming
out of those films because she is the
leader she's gonna get the blame clearly
what she's been trying to do with Star
Wars hasn't been working so get someone
else in there
you know Couture drangus genderqueer
okay like all right well Star Wars you
want the Benioff and Weiss trilogy down
below on all this [ __ ] subscribe to the
real rejects click the notification bell
subscribe to overlord because he's gonna
dominate the Star Wars meter just give
this studio over to him maybe he's got
the the overall site yes
and last but not least let's do up Tyler
Hague hey Tyler how's it going so we've
been talking to messages you saw your
last shout out John yeah I think it's
now time you demand a ps5 from Tyler
Hague Tyler listen buddy I Love You Man
and I feel like that love hasn't been
reciprocated well enough beyond your
generosity over many many many many many
many months of being our patron and
quite frankly I mean I'm working my ass
off for your love I think you're a
beautiful man and I wish you could
cradled me at night but I think a ps5
would probably do suffice wow you are a
terrible person
I am you demand a ps5 that's right from
longtime patrons already showed their
support see when he gave me a ps4 I'm a
daddy guy that kit was unexpected and
came out of nowhere that's a gift you're
demanding from him yeah Tyler I'm not
gonna talk to you Wow ja I'm sorry Tyler
I am separate buddy
hi I'm sorry you're being a real
Kathleen Kennedy about this you I don't
know what that should be this is gonna
become the new thing to say when you
don't like a decision variously Tyler I
love you whether or not you send me a
piece because you are a lovely lovely
thoughtful and caring human being
thanks Tyler be well